[موسيقى]
موسكو الاسلحه النوويه بالنسبه لروسيا هي
الرد الوحيد على التهديدات فاما ان ندمر
نظامهم او ان نموت معا وبوتن يجتمع بقاده
جيشه في الحرب بشكل عاجل فما الذي يجري
المطارات الروسيه في مرمى نيران الاوكران
والرد الروسي لا يتاخر واوروبا تتمسك
بالدعم العسكري لكياف من اجل السلام فكيف
يتم ذلك وروسيا ترد انتم تقودون قطارا
سريعا بدون مكابح والحرب الاوكرانيه تخلف
اكثر من 500 الف ضحيه فاي الطرفين هو
المتضرر الاكبر في النيجر الامور تحدث
وجيوش الاكواس تحت شد وتنتظر ساعه الصفر
والحلفاء يحضرون قواتهم بعدتهم والعتاد
وشراره الحرب تشتعل في اي لحظه اليابان
وتايوان فرائس سهله امام والصين فهل من
مغيث صبر موسكو ينفذ الخيارات صارت محدوده
والحرب لا نهايه لها والدب الروسي نفذ
صبره ولن ينتظر الى الابد او هكذا يقولها
الروس ليعلنها وزير الخارجيه الروسي
صراحه بان الاسلحه النوويه بالنسبه لروسيا
هي الرد الوحيد على التهديدات تصريحات
رجال بوتين تصب كلها في نهر واحد وهنا
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ديمثلي يؤكد
بانه اذا استغرق الامر سنوات او حتى عقود
فليكن ليس لدينا خيار اما ان ندمر نظامهم
السياسي المعادي او ان الغرب الجماعيه
سيمزق روسيا في النهايه الى اشلاء وفي هذه
اللحظه سنموت معا لا احد يريد هذا
وبتصريحات كهذه يبرز المصدر امامنا
لنتصفحه امامكم كما تشاهدون
امام الميكروفون الروسي الى الارض حيث
تدور المعارك الضاريه حيث كشف مصدر عسكري
روسي ان القوات الروسيه قامت بتطهير الضفه
اليسرى لنهر دينمبرو في مقاطعه خراس من
القوات الاوكرانيه بشكل كامل فيما ذكرت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها اسقطت
مقاتلتين اوكرانيا من طراز سخوي 25 في كل
من دوناتسك
وليس ذلك فحسب بل واعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه عن صد جميع هجمات قوتك والقضاء
على 975 عسكريا وتدمير مقر قياده الفيلق
العاشر الاوكراني بمقاطعه زابوريجيا
واسقاط 23 مسيره لقوتكاف الاعداد كبيره
وتتحدث عن نفسها ولكنها هكذا كما جاءت من
المصدر في الموقع الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه
واما نحن من جانبنا فلا نؤكد ولا ننفي فقط
ننقل الخ كما هو وهنا جاء الرد الاوكراني
حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه احباطه
هجوم بطائره مسيره على مقاطعه موسكو واكدت
ايضا اصابه طائره عسكريه جراه هجوم
اوكرانيا اخر بمسيره على مطار عسكري
بمقاطعه نوفو شمال العاصمه واضافت الوزاره
انها اخمدت حريقا اندلع في مدرج المطار
جراء الهجوم وبالعوده للاراضي الاوكرانيه
اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه اسقاط صاروخ
الاوكراني
شبه جزيره القرم الروسيه واما القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه فقالت انها تمكنت من
اسقاط 15 مسيره من طراز شاهد استهدفت شمال
ووسط وغرب اوكرانيا مقابل مقتل 6
اوكرانيين واصابه 37 اخرين في هجوم
صاروخيه على تشيرنهاف بينما كان الكرملين
قد كشف ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
زرق العمليه العسكريه الروسيه اوكرانيا
والتقى بكبار القاده العسكريين الاخرين
وذلك بعد اعلان اوكرانيا عن تحقيق مكاسب
في الهجوم المضاد ضد القوات الروسيه على
الجبهه الجنوبيه الشرقيه وتلخيصا لاكثر من
عام ونصف العام من الحرب الطاحنه في
اوكرانيا نقلت صحيفه عن مسؤولين امريكيين
ان عدد القتلى والجرح في صفوف القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه يقترب من 500 الف
واشار المسؤولون الامريكيون الى ان
الخسائر العسكريه الروسيه تقترب من 300
الف ويشمل العدد ما يصل الى 120 الف قتيل
اما الخسائر الاوكرانيه فقدرها المسؤولون
بما يقرب من 70 الف قتيل واكثر من 100 الف
جريح يا لها من اعداد مضحكه قد لا تعبر عن
الواقع ولكنها تعبر عما جاء في المصدر
الذي يتحدث معكم نقلت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان عدد القتلى
والجرحى في صفوف القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه يقترب من 500 الف
واشار المسؤولون الامريكيون الى ان
الخسائر العسكريه الروسيه تقترب من 300
الف ويشمل العدد ما يصل الى 120 الف قتيل
اما الخسائر الاوكرانيه فقدرها المسؤولون
بما يقرب من 70 الف قتيل واكثر من مئه الف
جريح ومن الاحصائيات الى المساعدات حيث
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان طيارها
سيباشرون تدريبات على تشغيل مقاتلات من
طراز اف 16 قبل نهايه شهر اغسطس الجاري في
الدنمارك وبحسب شبكه سي ان ان واشنطن وفقط
على اعطائك مواد تعليميه تحتوي على
معلومات حساسه حول التكنولوجيا الامريكيه
ليشبه السفير الروسي لدى واشنطن انا طولي
اناطوف من قرروا تزويد كييف بمقاتله اف 16
بمن يركب قطارا سريعا بلا متابع محذرا من
عواقب مثل هذه المغامرات واشار الى ان
البيت الابيض دفع نفسه الى طريق مسدود
ويتخذ المزيد والمزيد من القرارات
المجنونه للخروج من هذا المازق من جهته
زعما مفوض السياسه الخارجيه بالاتحاد
الاوروبي
ان تخلى الغرب عن تقديم المساعدات
العسكريه لكياف لن يؤدي الى السلام في
اوكرانيا واضاف ان اوروبا تعمل بوسعها
لبدء مفاوضات للسلام تعترف بوجود معتد
وضحيه طبول الحرب تقرا فالنيجر الامور
تحدث حقا هذه المره ويبدو ان فتيل الحرب
قد بدا بالاشتعال فجوش ايكوس تحت شد
والاهداف تم تحديدها والحرب تم اعلانها
لكن دون موعد محدد لاشعال الفتيل نعم هناك
ايكو استضعوا اللمسه الاخيره للتدخل
العسكري حيث قال مفوض السلم والانف في
ايكوس عبد الفتاح موسى ان تكتل حدد ساعه
التدخل العسكري في النيجر لكن لن يتم
الاعلان عنها مؤكدا ان التكتل منفتح على
الدبلوماسيه لكنه لن ينخرط في حوار من دون
جدوى مع المجلس العسكري في نيامي يا الهي
اليس هناك عوده للورائيه هؤلاء الا تعلمون
ما الذي ستجنيه الحرب عليكم وعلى جيرانكم
وعلى المنطقه بل وعلى العالم اجمع ضعوا
ذلك في حسبانكم ولكن مجموعه ايكوست تتراجع
هنا قليلا حيث افادت مصادر الدبلوماسيه ان
وفدا من
اجراء محادثات مع المجلس العسكري في
محاوله دبلوماسيه اخيره للتوصل الى حل
سلمي للازمه واما في النيجر فافاد مصدر
عسكري بوصول طائرات مقاتله ومروحيه هجوميه
من مالي وبوركينا فاسو لدعم القوات
المسلحه بالنيجر في مواجهه تدخل عسكري
محتمل من قبل ايكواس هذا ونقلت صحيفه موند
عن حسوم مسعود مستشار رئيس النيجر المعزول
محمد بازون تاكيده تفويض السلطات السابقه
فرنسا بالتدخل العسكري لحمايه نظام بازل
فلتتريث قليلا يا هؤلاء وخذوا العبر من
اوكرانيا والسودان فالتدخل الخارجي لا
ياتي بخير ابدا
الاحداث والتطورات اعلن رؤس الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه واليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه في بيان مشترك عزمهم اجراء
مناورات عسكريه ضخمه بشكل سنوي مؤكدين
انفتاحهم على الحوار مع كوريا الشماليه
دون شروط مسبقه والى اليابان وكرد فعل
لتحركات موسكو في المنطقه اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع اليابانيه انها نشرت طائرات
المقاتله بعد رصد طائرتين روسيتين لجمع
المعلومات وهما تحلقان ذها وايابا بين بحر
اليابان وبحر الصين الشرقي في الصين اجرى
الجيش الصيني تدريبات عسكريه جويه وبحريه
حول جزيره تايوان ردا على زياره نائب رئيس
تايوان ويليام لاين الى امريكا وقال الجيش
الصيني ان التدريبات كانت تحذيرا خطيرا
للقوات الانفصاليه في مقاله وزاره الدفاع
التايوانيه انها رصدت ابتداء من صباح
السبت الماضي 42 طائره وثماني سفن صينيه
تشارك في تدريبات حول الجزيره وهناك اذان
تايوان اجراء الصيني للتدريبات معتبره
انها لن تعزز الاستقرار في الجزيره
[موسيقى]